[Musique]
Anthony Saint-Léger bonsoir bonsoir
Audrey bonsoir à tous je lisais tout à
l'heure en sommaire on va parler du
Burkina Faso le coup d'État a eu lieu il
y a près d'une semaine et il a donné
lieu à une prolifération de fausses
informations notamment concernant
l'arrivée et l'intervention sur le
territoire burkinabé de soldats
étrangers en première ligne des Français
oui preuve en sont deux vidéos relayées
depuis le coup d'État de vidéo que l'on
va découvrir ensemble elle monte chacune
un avion qui largue des parachutistes
dans cette première la voix nous dit
qu'il faut se poser des questions que la
situation est préoccupante et certains
internautes vont même plus loin comme
ces deux là par exemple celui-ci de nous
dire que c'est parachutistes sont
français vous le voyez que l'Élysée est
donc derrière tout ça pour sécuriser le
fils d'Hannibal le lieutenant-colonel
chassé du pouvoir cet autre par exemple
d'évoquer des forces
étrangère d'autres ont évoqué à des
forces
occidentales voilà pour cette première
vidéo pour ce qui est de la seconde elle
montre aussi je vous le disais un avion
qui largue des parachutistes mais cette
fois dans cette vidéo la voix est en
mourrée l'une des langues du Burkina
Faso on parle de soldats à Bobo on va y
revenir aller faire parachutage au Sahel
on ne vous veut pas ici c'est ce qu'on
peut entendre aussi dans cette audio et
certains internautes donc de
s'interroger s'agit-il d'une
intervention française des commentaires
qui en fait ont profité finalement de la
confusion qui a marqué cette journée de
vendredi dernier une rumeur
souvenez-vous avait fait croire que le
lieutenant colonel Damiba avait été
placé sous protection française Paris
qui avait démenti tout de suite tout
implication et que sait-on de ces vidéos
alors dans les deux vidéos en question
il est question de Bobo bobo pour
bobo Jul assu qui est une ville du
Burkina Faso et pas n'importe laquelle
elle est au sud-ouest mais c'est surtout
la capitale économique de la ville la
rédaction des Observateurs de France 24
a contacté à des habitants de cette
ville et ils ont effectivement confirmé
avoir aperçu des parachutistes dans le
ciel de cette ville entre le 26 et le 30
septembre et ne pas s'en être à l'armée
davantage et pour cause puisque la ville
abrite à la fois le centre d'instruction
des troupes aéroportées et le 25e
régiment des parachutistes commandos du
Burkina Faso les Observateurs de France
24 ont également contacté des sources
officielles en l'occurrence
l'agendarmerie et l'armée et ils nous
ont effectivement confirmés qu'il s'agit
qu'il s'agissait pardon des exercices de
saut de parachutistes mené donc par des
militaires de l'armée burkinabè et
essentiellement des stagiaires de
l'Académie Georges namuano
les derniers sauts précistons également
ont eu lieu dans la matinée du 37
septembre avant même donc que les
rumeurs de coup d'État ne brissent deux
autres exemples de vidéos des
contextualisés oui alors le premier
exemple et relatif au sentiment
anti-français on va découvrir la vidéo
en question regardez on y voit
beaucoup de monde finalement des torches
à la main et certains internautes de
nous faire dire qu'il s'agit bien de
Burkinabè d'habitants de Ouagadougou
hostile aux forces françaises et alliées
et précisé même que les forces armées
françaises seraient aux portes de la
ville et bien lorsque l'on recherche
cette image on la retrouve sur Tik Tok
regardez mes en date du 8 août 2022 et
en l'occurrence cette image illustre le
festival du feu on est à Yendi au
sud-ouest du Ghana voilà pour le premier
exemple pour ce du second c'est
également une vidéo que l'on va
découvrir ensemble regardez alors on y
voit écrit tant pis tant pis c'est un
quartier de Ouagadougou la capitale et
l'internaute ou un des internautes en
tout cas qui la partage
dit ceci à temps puis en ce moment à
l'heure de la publication il faut
comprendre que c'est entre la nuit du 2
au 3 octobre donc quelques jours après
le coup d'État sauf que lorsqu'on fait
une recherche et bien cette vidéo ces
images elles ont été partagées regardez
sur Tik Tok mais c'est surtout le 30
janvier dernier lors de la Coupe
d'Afrique des nations le Burkina Faso
venait de se qualifier pour la
demi-finale et donc rejoignait le
Sénégal merci beaucoup Anthony
Saint-Léger pour ses explications